So that's what a human being is like in terms of his or her output.
And so what you see,
if you look at a sensory homonculus it's quite similar except the feet are
bigger.
The Genitalia or bigger,
logically they don't have much motor utility,
but they have a lot of sensory utility.
But the rest of it's quite similar.
So there's,
you know,
the motor and the sensory homonculus are quite similar.
But I'm going to talk about the motor homonculus because it's sort of the action
representation.
While,
so what are human beings like?
Well,
we're all hands.
That's the first thing,
you know.
And if you,
if you do that,
there's no,
it's unbelievably high resolution.
Your fingertips and,
and,
and the,
that sensory.
But we can manipulate our hands like crazy.
Like they're unbelievably articulated,
right?
And that's the thing that makes us able to change the world.
It makes us what dolphins aren't.
And so a huge part of our brain is devoted towards being able to move our hands.
That enables us to take things apart,
put them together.
And then once we learned to take things apart and put them together,
we can talk about how we do that.
And that's a lot of what we're doing.
And that's the hands and the mouth and the tongue.
Roughly speaking.
Here's how I took something to apart chaos.
Here's what I made out of it.
Order,
here's how I did it.
And then you receive that and you're happy about it.
And then you can do the same thing.
And that's imitation.
It's facilitated by language.
It's like,
here's what I did with my body.
I'm propagating the cross space.
You're taking it,
mapping it onto your body.
Now you can do the same thing.
Yeah,
and that's,
you know,
it might be simple like this is how you pick up a rock,
but it might be complicated.
Like here's how you go after the dragon of chaos.
Right?
And so that's it sort of maps onto that hierarchy.
This thing we've talked about in some detail,
this,
when you're telling a story to people,
when you're informing them about something,
you can talk to them at a very high level of resolution,
which you do with your child.
Here's how you slice up some Broccoli,
right?
But then you move up the obstruction and say,
here's how you act like a civilized person at the dinner table.
Right?
And that's part of being a good person.
So you can tell stories about,
I just went and saw Logan,
which I really liked by the way,
it's super violent,
but I really did like it.
Uh,
it's,
it's got a very elegant,
mythological structure,
which is not surprising,
but,
um,
there's a scene in this Logan movie.
He,
he,
uh,
it's not a spoiler.
He has this child with him who has not been,
who's been raised roughly in a laboratory,
and she has absolutely no table manners.
And so they're sitting at a dinner with some people that they've run into and
she's eating like a total barbarian.
And of course,
everybody's eyebrows,
her race.
Like,
where did this person come from?
So that the fact that that high order behavior isn't there is something that's
acts of extraordinary interest.
Everyone.
And so you know,
you,
you teach your children micro strategies and you teach the macro strategies and
some of the macro strategies you're teaching them,
you don't even understand because you know,
you know the strategies they're built into you because of an evolutionary
process,
roughly speaking.
And you say things like it doesn't matter whether you win or lose,
it matters how you play the game and you don't understand what that means.
Although you know it's right and you try to act that out for your children and
they incorporate it in their action,
even though they can't represent it,
they cannot come up with a fully articulated representation of what that means.
And so they're like children,
the Piaget and children.
Children can only play by themselves to begin with while they're integrating
themselves internally.
Then they start to play in parallel with other children.
So you'll,
you're to,
you play your game,
that child plays his or her gape little interaction,
but you can't unite the games.
Then you're between two and four.
You start to be able to unite the games.
And you can either do that by acting them out.
You can do this.
Even with the younger child,
they can catch peekaboo very rapidly.
But once you're between two and four and you start getting linguistic,
you could start saying,
well,
let's play this game and that means we're going to unite our attention towards a
particular goal.
We're going to unite our motor activity and maybe cooperate and compete towards
that goal.
So beginning of of the social structure,
it's the beginning of the social structure and you get really good at that
between two and four,
but you don't necessarily know what you're doing.
You can't say it.
So Piaget's experiments indicated that if you take children,
maybe they've got to the point where they can play quite a social game.
Maybe there are five or six,
they're playing marbles.
You take them out of the game and you say,
okay,
tell me the rules of the game of marbles.
They give incoherent representations.
Why?
Because their behavior is more sophisticated than their representation.
You see as soon as you understand that,
that is a wild thing to understand because it answers the question.
For example,
how can you have dreams that tells you things you don't know?
You think,
well,
how the hell can that possibly be?
You're coming up with the damn dream.
How can the dream tell you things you don't know?
Or analogously.
How can people tell stories that contain information that they don't understand
and answer is the information is coded in our behavior.
Okay,
so we'll go back to a chimpanzee troop.
All the chimpanzees in the troop?
No,
the dominance hierarchy structure.
But if you take a chimpanzee out from the troop and say,
what's the dominant structure?
The chimpanzee is going to do whatever a chimpanzee does,
it's not going to have a little conversation with you about the nature of the
dominance hierarchy.
So it can act out its knowledge and it might even be able to represent it an
image,
but it can't articulate it.
Well,
why would we be any different?
We aren't obviously,
because we're more complex than we understand.
So the fact that we're more complex than we understand means that we contain
information that we cannot articulate.
Why can't that reveal itself?
It does all the time.
You have a revelation.
Aha,
I get it.
Well,
what is that?
It's you.
Maybe you're in psychotherapy,
and we talk about some things about your past,
and we say,
well,
this happened.
Then this happened,
then this happened.
We say,
look,
there's a pattern.
Wow.
And it's overwhelming.
It's like now there's a concordance between your knowledge and the things that
you're acting out,
and that's what comes as a revelation.
So one of the things that happens in exodus,
Moses is leading his people through the deserts.
Classic you shaped story.
They're in a tyranny to begin with,
right?
So that's the,
that's the insufficient present.
That's the old order.
Then they crossed the water,
the destructive water.
That's chaos.
Like the flood.
Then they're out in the desert wandering without direction.
They start worshiping idols,
they're wandering without direction.
And then Moses goes up on the mountain,
which is,
by the way,
what happens in Logan,
just because if you're going to go see it,
you might as well know that because it's a journey up the mountain.
Um,
he goes up the mountain and he gets rules revealed to them.
Well,
the way the story is structured,
it's extraordinarily interesting because Moses takes us people away from this
tyranny,
tyrannical structure,
but they don't go from tyranny to paradise to the promise land in one move.
That isn't how it works.
They have to,
they go from a tyranny to absolute chaos where everyone is fighting and killing
each other and having a terrible time of it and half starving and,
and having to pass through the Red Sea.
Like it's,
they go from tyranny to catastrophe before they go to higher order.
And Moses doesn't even make it to the place of higher order.
He dies before he gets there.
So it's,
it's quite the catastrophe.
And the Israelites are all confused when they're out in the desert because even
though they were in a tyranny and they were slaves,
now they're nowhere and they don't know anything.
It's not good.
And so a lot of them actually start thinking about how good the damn tyranny was
compared to wandering around in the desert,
which is exactly what happened to the Soviet Union,
right?
In Russia.
Now there's huge nostalgia for the Stalinist era.
So these stories,
they,
they're always true.
They're always happening.
So anyways,
what happens to Moses is that the story is quite interesting.
So the Israelites start to fight amongst themselves,
which of course they do because there's no higher order authority.
And so then Moses sits and judges like literally like a judge.
He sits for hours every day and the squabbling Israelites come up and say,
you know,
he did this to me and no,
you did this to me.
And,
and so then Moses has to figure out who's right and who's wrong.
And he's doing this for like hours and hours for days and days,
for weeks and weeks,
for months.
It's like the origin of English common law.
It's exactly what happened with common law because in common law,
what happens is that you have all the rights.
There are,
if you to have a dispute,
you go before the judiciary,
you sort out the dispute.
That becomes a precedent.
Now,
that's part of the body of laws.
The body of laws is what you act out.
That's why it's a body.
Well,
that's what Moses does.
So he's sitting there making judgments.
Very,
very finely tuned,
discrete moral judgements.
You know how difficult that is when two people have a dispute to try to figure
out how to mediate between that?
You don't know who's lying,
who's telling the truth.
You don't know exactly what an acceptable solution would be like.
It's really ridiculously hard work.
So he walks through this entire process of continual judicial intermediation.
Then he goes up the mountain and what does he get?
Tablet of rules.
Well,
why?
he spent his 10,000 hours investigating the structure of morality in a practical
way,
and it goes,
Bang,
this is what we've been doing.
These are the rules.
It's not like there's no rules to begin with and don'ts.
Those are imposed because that wouldn't work.
It doesn't work that way.
You have to take how people are,
extract out what the pattern of what they are is reflect that back to them.
Well that's,
that's the story of Moses and it's,
it's,
it's a myth.
It's a metal story.
It's a story about how rules come to be.
We act a certain way.
We have certain kinds of expectations.
We have certain kinds of disputes out of that,
a pattern,
a pattern way of being emerges.
Then we map the pattern way of being.
We say,
well look,
here's the rules.
There's 10 of them or however many you want to extract.
Right?
I mean it's,
it's a moving target in some sense.
Don't kill other people.
That's a bad idea.
Don't steal what other people have,
honor your parents,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I mean,
these are,
you could come up with a different basic set of rules,
but there'd be some overlap and those aren't bad to begin with.
Kirsten were far more rules than that,
but those were the central ones.
And so then he might say,
hey,
if you took all 10 of those rules and you tried to extract out one rule from
them,
that would be at the top of the hierarchy,
what would that be?
And in Western culture,
the idea there is that do unto others as you would have them do unto you,
is the rule that it's the matter rule that guides all other rules.
Sorta like the one ring in the,
in the Lord of the rings.